my trip is going pretty much according
to plan that gives me the idea of trying
a few tricks with my scooter first the
dying Swan then look ma no hands hard
but I managed eight tenths of a second
and the blindfold slalom made it now
back to real life
so we're right through verenia can be
great fun but also can be great pain the
last hilt for me off my schedule I've
now done 1198 kilometers in 37 days then
in bot flanken heusen I discovered the
world's second farthest leaning church
tower at an angle of 4.7 6 degrees it
tilts eight tenths of a degree more than
the Leaning Tower of Pisa the leaning
tower of three needs over quite a lot
Wow why did their built its land Germans
are famous for thriving for position why
does the tower lean so much for like
maybe there are lots of moles in but
funkin house that's looking almighty I
don't know maybe because of all the
mining because it's been hollowed out by
water underneath
and that's the right answer is the mayor
worried the tower will fall down and
bury half the town he's alone no we're
not worried it's been leaning for
centuries already it's constantly being
monitored so I don't see any danger or
reason to worry okay a very optimistic
mayor but Germans are known as masters
of precision and he seems to be
glorifying the opposite is he proud or
embarrassed pollut I stayed for the
crowd of course did she proud to have
the world's most slanted tower not even
Pisa can match it so we're very proud of
our Leaning Tower Wow in addition to
leaning towers Germany has other extreme
buildings the tallest church spire in
the world is own Minster at 162 metres
the tallest building in Germany is in
Frankfort the Comets Punk 259 meters and
the biggest hall without indoor supports
is the I Eddie of near Berlin 360 meters
long 210 wide and 107 tall it houses a
tropical spa
the mayor gives me his personal
permission to climb the church tower
okay climbing up feels weird this land
pushes you against the wall to the right
and I'm really scared it's no joke I'm
scared I throw a pot of cottage cheese
overboard to confirm the amount of
overhang look out below
according to my splat test there's an
overhang of an incredible seven meters
30 almost three more than the official
one I'm amazed the towers still standing
at all before I leave I take the
prettiest leaning pictures of my
firehouse and citizens in front of the
tower who can manage to lean as much as
the building this chimney sweep bends to
the left and ends up almost horizontal
this woman leads quite far as well and
uses her arms to capture the true
essence of the tower
and my third test subject leans in slow
motion and incredibly ends up at a tilt
of exactly four point seven six degrees
slightly dizzy I continue on my trip
it's still a long way to the southern
tip of Germany